meine tolle Kollegin Nina schick hat
sich gerade eben darüber aufgeregt dass
in ihrer Heimatstadt Düsseldorf künftig
zwei gilt und zwar auch im Theater in
der Oper und im Museum städtische
Kultureinrichtungen für die von der
Stadt die städtischen Kultureinrichtung
ab 1 November also bis dahin können
jetzt die umgehend noch mal kurz die
Zeit nutzen und dürfen dann noch mal ins
Museum aber ab dem 1 November dann nicht
mehr ich muss dir bei deiner These oder
deiner Meinung sehr sehr sehr sehr viel
Recht geben denn ich finde dass wir
endlich viel mehr darüber sprechen
müssen wann das ganze beendet wird Jens
Spahn hat sie heute versucht hat gesagt
die epidemische Lage endet jetzt da kann
man sagen herzlichen Glückwunsch auch
entspannt
nach sehr vielen Monaten wo immer noch
weiter panikgeschürt würde wurde dass
die Zahlen hochgehen könnten das jetzt
wieder der Winter kommt das alles ganz
dramatisch wird also eigentlich hatte
man das Gefühl bei einigen Experten und
damit meine ich nicht jetzt nicht Karl
Lauterbach sondern zum Beispiel Frau
Brinkmann und andere hatte man das
Gefühl dass wir eigentlich hier im
Winter kurz vor einem Lockdown stehen
ich finde
ExpertInnen wie Frau Brinkmann täten gut
daran sich für das was sie da vor
wenigen Monaten behauptet haben nämlich
dass die Zahl nach oben geht und alles
ganz schlimm wird und dramatisch wird
sich jetzt einmal zu erklären es gab
oder sogar zu entschuldigen es gab dann
ganz fürs Beispiel ich war in der
österreichischen Talkshow zu Gast und da
hat mir ein Virologe erzählt dass ein
Freund von ihm Virologe in Österreich
sich entschuldigt hat bei der
Bevölkerung als er hat ein falsches
Szenario ausgemalt hat sich dafür dann
aber auch entschuldigt und was mich so
ein bisschen stört ist es gibt es bei
uns in Deutschland ja gar nicht alle
erzählen nur ach nein man konnte nichts
mehr vorsehen und Karl Lauterbach
hierher ein und der anschauen
dafür dass man sich entschuldigen könnte
naja gesagt doppelt werden ein Fehler
machen und dafür
Szenario vom Virologen der einfach sagt
liebe Kinder ist tut mir leid dass ihr
irgendwie so lange im Lockdown war es
tut mir leid ich würde das
durch den Kopf jetzt da wir alle
erkennen aufgrund der sehr viel höheren
Impfquote als wir angenommen haben dass
das Ganze zu Ende geht und dass die
große Aufregung abhebt und dass die
pandemische Notlage beendet wird dann
sollte auch der Staat die Politik den
Mut haben 2G an öffentlichen Plätzen zu
verbieten also 2G darf es aus meiner
Sicht nur im privaten Einrichtungen
Restaurants Bars Cafés da ist jeder
Inhaber autonom das zu verhängen wenn er
will aber an öffentlichen Plätzen also
damals fehlt ja nur noch der Bahnhof
dass man nicht mehr mit der Eisenbahn
fahren kann ja aber in Theatern und und
so weiter da zahlt ja der Mensch der
nicht rein darf auch noch durch seine
Steuern für ohne dass er dann rein darf
das geht überhaupt nicht das muss man
dringend eingrenzen jetzt da das ganze
sowieso zu Ende geht ich habe mich
gefragt ob wir bald Weltmeister im
ausgrenzen werden wollen an sie haben
mich wirklich gefragt ob Deutschland
irgendwie jetzt eine neue ob wir da
Weltmeister werden wollen wenn man in
Holland ist wie ich am Wochenende keine
Maske alles ist gut und hier kommen wir
hin und debattieren über sowas und ich
muss wirklich sagen diese zwei-regelung
also es ist traurig dass es Düsseldorf
ist jetzt eine Stadt von euch getroffen
die Heimatstadt hätte ich nämlich die
ganze Zeit betont wie gut dass ich aus
Düsseldorf stamme hier ist es meine
eigene meiner Heimatstadt würde man
sowas nicht machen welche ist es denn
dies liegt in Thüringen
wir müssen jetzt eher über den freedom
der reden und nicht mehr über diese zwei
geregelungen aber ab 1 November das
finde ich auch immer so lustig und
vielleicht kannst du mir das erklären
Paul du bist viel mehr an der Politik
dran als ich ab 1 November gilt das
jetzt aber wenn wir doch gerade so ein
horrorzustand haben ist das jetzt
verhängt werden muss warum dann nicht ab
heute was bringt es jetzt bis 1 November
das habe ich noch nie verstanden in der
ganzen corona-zeit nie warum vor Ort und
meine Zeit haben als würde ich dann
gekauften gibt vermutlich nein ich
glaube es hat tatsächlich etwas mit den
Verordnungen zu tun die das geschrieben
werden müssen und so weiter und so fort
und dann muss ich sagen in deiner
Heimatstadt Düsseldorf bin ich politisch
jetzt nicht so gut vernetzt von daher
weiß ich nicht was ich dafür
lokalische Gründe geben können also man
hat ein Datum bekommen und dann ab dann
gilt das immer ich fand das immer
merkwürdig weil wenn es wie gesagt so
ein Horror Szenario ist da muss doch ab
sofort gelten ich finde wir haben auch
einen gewissen freiheitlichen Anspruch
als als Bundesrepublik als Deutschland
den wir auch als freiheitliches Land
waren müssen auch gegenüber denjenigen
die sagen ich will mich nicht impfen
lassen es gibt Menschen mit
Vorerkrankung ab sie haben große Angst
Angst hat sich da vor sich impfen zu
lassen was ich nicht wissen wie wirkt
das bei mir und unsere Justizministerin
sagt ja es wird keine Impfpflicht geben
das ist eine Impfpflicht durch die
Hintertür warum denn bitte nicht wenn
ich mich frei teste und ein aktuellen
Test dabei aber der sagt heute Mittag
war ich negativ dann ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie in den
letzten sechs Stunden positiv geworden
bin auch nicht groß und größer als
impfdurchbruch
in meinem Rachen als geimpfte kann
genauso eine hohe Viruslast sein wie
nehme ich geimpfen ich teste mich ja
nicht mehr das heißt theoretisch auch
theoretisch
ansteckend auch als geimpft
sicherer eine Impfung für andere Leute
vor allem nehmen diese Menschen auch
noch aktiv an der pandemiebekämpfung
teilen sie gehen sich testen lassen das
heißt sie sind involviert sie wollen da
Gutes tun und das sind im Prinzip dann
die die man vor den Kopf stößt also an
der Stelle wird es nicht kontrovers
werden natürlich geht das so nicht es
ist eine gesellschaftliche Spaltung in
Teilen natürlich die impfpflichtet wenn
ich das richtig sehe reagiert die FDP in
Nordrhein-Westfalen mit mit der CDU
Düsseldorf liegt in Nordrhein-Westfalen
schon klar aber das ist ja Landesrecht
die corona-bekämpfung die haben sich ja
nur sozusagen freiwillig zusammengetan
mit Ausnahme dieser pandemischen Notlage
der vom Bundesamt beschlossen worden ist
sollte man die nach den
nordrhein-westfälischen landesligieren
Akt der Freiheit vollziehen und der
Stadt Düsseldorf verbieten 2G in
öffentlichen Plätzen einzuführen aber
habt ihr nicht immer in städtischen
Kultureinrichtungen aber ja Corona
warbert irgendwie weiter dahin es gibt
jetzt niemanden der das Zentrale in der
Hand hält niemand der sagt okay da geht
es lang sondern ist es wahrt und es
beschäftigt uns vielleicht noch ein
halbes Jahr vielleicht noch ein Jahr
vielleicht noch zwei Jahre und niemand
macht den an den den tatsächlich
das Ziel hier das Ganze für beendet und
kurioserweise gucken wir bei den
Sondierungen gar nicht drauf ob die dazu
irgendwas beschlossen haben da steht
nichts drin haben die darüber geredet
aber das müssten sie doch ich meine das
ist ein Ding was jeden Bürger jeden Tag
ja wir haben das Fehler gesehen während
des Wahlkampfes war ein ist eines der
wesentlichen Themen was die Menschen
bewegt hat es wurde nicht debattiert
trotzdem hat im Osten sicherlich die AFD
solche Ergebnisse erzielt weil sie
thematisiert dann lass uns doch mal
darüber sprechen wer weil das Thema so
wichtig ist Gesundheitsminister werden
könnte der wenn ihr viele Namen
gehandelt meine These ist Olaf Scholz
wird unter allen Umständen verhindern
dass das Gesundheitsministerium an ihnen
geht damit er nicht Karl Lauterbach
dorthin setzen muss weil da geht es so
viel Druck aus der Basis ich sehe schon
Zornesfalten bei Olivia ist wenn ich den
Namen aber
sie in der FDP in über ihrer letzten
regier Beteiligung da war erst Philipp
Rösler Gesundheitsminister dann Daniel
Bar also sie haben so ein bisschen
Erfahrung durchaus in dem Bereich wer
das ein Ministerium was sie gerne hätten
in dieser Zeit sie hat mich schon zum
Finanzministerium nicht geäußert und da
ging es um meinen Chef werde ich bei
anderen ministerialspiele
kontrollieren können
die FDP will das Ministerium nicht die
will es nicht Gesundheit ja will sie
nicht aus Angst vor der nächsten
Pandemie hat anderes im Auge es sind ja
spannende eingesetzt es gibt ja
vermutlich an
digitalisierungsministerium viel
spannender und die bei Gesundheit haben
sie schon mehrfach die Finger verbrannt
die FDP also und die die SPD will den
Lauterbach nicht sie könnte kaum an ihm
vorbeigehen sie hat vermutlich sechs
Minister drei davon sind Frauen bleiben
drei Männer da ist schon mal Herr Heil
Arbeit und Soziales dann Herr Klingbeil
das hoffe ich sogar Verteidigung
dann könnte er wie heißt der
niedersächsische Innenminister
ja es gibt natürlich nicht weil du drei
Niedersachsen dann für die Parteien
was ich aus der SPD habe drei Frauen
sind ja schon abgezogen nein
du hast aber vergessen das ist Olaf
Scholz gibt den Kanzleramtsminister
Wolfgang Schmidt das sind dann schon
zwei Männer das heißt es bleiben
eigentlich nur noch zwei Ministerien
können
was da los ist sind alle nrw-kandidaten
alle Männer ja ja aber jetzt erzählen
sie mal ein bisschen aus dem Nähkästchen
aber du hast auf jeden Fall
natürlich die Replik geben dass ich
natürlich sehr wohl glaube dass wir gute
Leute haben die jedes Ministerium aber
wir haben sie doch eingeladen das ist
zumindest dass sie zumindest den
Anspruch erheben dass
technologieministerium führen zu wollen
als Technologie Experte und dann war das
einladungsmanagement natürlich an der
Stelle falsche weil auch das werde ich
hier nicht erleben ich habe wirklich
mein Gefühl ist so ich mache mal
Fernseher an und schaut die FDP unsere
sind so wahnsinnig langweilig geworden
also auch Christian Lindner wenn er
jetzt in Interviews ist es so präsidial
und toll und alles wird wahnsinnig
gemütlich und so wo ist da die Sprache
genau
für Presse schaffen dann natürlich nicht
die dass die wahlvoraussetzung auch
nicht genauso ich glaube nicht dass man
uns gewählt hat um irgendwie
Presseartikel zu produzieren und
abendformate zu füllen ich glaube die
Leute wollen dass sich das Land
verändert und dass wir das ernst nehmen
und wir sind ja Dinge angeschrieben
angesprochen worden vorhergehende
Regierungen und
regierungsbildungsversuche und insofern
ist es ganz normal dass sowohl die
einzelnen Personen ich bin jetzt auch
das zweite mal wieder gewählt man sieht
Dinge anders hier geht es jetzt auch um
eine Regierung das ist ein andere
Seriösität wie eine Opposition ganz
einfach und ich glaube das ist das Gebot
der Stunde und verstehe das ist
natürlich das für dieses Format hier von
Nachteilen ist aber das ist so
sympathisch das ist nicht unser primärz
ich sage voraus jetzt sicher ist ja
dieser Haltung aber ich sage voraus dass
wir nicht lange werden warten müssen bis
diese inhaltliche Bestimmung auch durch
Indiskretionen dann und ich frage mich
was wird aus Wolfgang Kubicki Bilder
Ministerposten wieder
werden oder er wird nicht funktionieren
nein nein
ich glaube das ist zwischen ich glaube
die Geschichte die hat ihm sehr
geschadet also Respekt vor dieses
wunderbare Interview aber während des
Wahlkampf so eine Sache rauszuhauen wie
er gesagt hat dass er gesagt hat ich
habe quasi unterlaufen
sehr intern
gestartet und nicht nur den Spacken ich
glaube nicht
wobei ich glaube dass jede Partei ein
Mann braucht der auch die Wahrheiten des
Volkes so ausspricht digital
mein Tipp geht zu den Grünen okay
das halten wir fest für eine der
nächsten Sendung
geben
[Musik]